okay so i'm going to tell you a little
story okay be me record an episode in
rollercoaster 3 for you tutorial series
for quite a while and then close the
game and realize that you didn't save
that's very much me and then you repair
all that and record another episode and
then it turns out that the headset you
were using is finally dead and this
actually kind of made me cry inside
because this means that my favorite
headset that i've been using for all of
these let's plays for over a year now is
now officially dead it's almost been
that before but it's officially dead now
but i do have some good news as well
because um also the quality of the video
is really bad something happened to obs
as well so everything is going wrong but
as you could see i did change the color
of the sidewalks over there so that's
actually something good and that's a
good message that i want to spread
because i had to repair things and on
accident i chose to i chose to use the
wrong color and then it turned out that
that color actually looked very good so
that's really awesome so sometimes
things like that can also be a great
thing so that's really cool
now what i want to cover in this episode
and um
i haven't even set this yet but
since my headset died i am actually
talking over this video uh so it's not
live so i'm sorry if it doesn't exactly
match up with with what's going on in
the video but what i want to talk about
this time is um
some terra painting and foliage now you
could see that i turned the grid off and
that's actually a very important thing
when it comes to terra painting and
foliage since i normally only say that
you have to at all times turn the grid
on i would say that for terror painting
and foliage you should turn the grid off
really it's it just helps making things
look um well you can pretty much see
what everything is going to look like
and um it really helps if you just turn
the grid off of course for buildings and
stuff like that it doesn't really but
in this case it's it's just it's an
exception but basically i'm going to
start off with the terror painting and
i'm going to do the infamous infamous
infamous method of the
the chessboard pattern and this is
actually one of the
worst things probably when it comes to
terra painting but i just love the way
that this looks so basically the idea is
and i've i think i've covered this
before also in a tutorial but i do want
to talk about this yet again because
it's a very important thing and it can
really help make things look so much
better you take this grass texture or
anything you like really it doesn't
really matter and then you start making
a pattern like this with rocks or
anything else that you really like and
then you start in filling the middle
squares with other things
now what's happening over here is that
you get the two textures and they start
mixing so as you can see you get the
dark rocky rough rock texture and it's
mixing with the cross texture and in the
end you get a somewhat darker grass
texture that i i just really love this
this is probably one of the best things
in rollercoaster second three really
when i when i just found out about this
holy my my life had been a lie up
to that point i felt like i was reborn
basically so this is this is awesome
really and um but as you can see this is
also quite annoying well since you do
have to
well basically fill all those squares
one by one and it does take a lot of
time and
well a lot of effort as well and yeah
that's somewhat of a nuisance when you
look at it that way but really the
result is so amazing that i would
recommend it either way
unless you're bored or um you don't want
to do it or you just don't like the
result but i do so i really love this
method and i pretty much use it all the
time as long as i can as long as i don't
forget it because um if you know me you
know that i forget pretty much
everything in my life ever and
what i'm doing at this point
is when it comes to mixing textures uh
what you can do is just mix the same two
textures everywhere but it works the
best if you kind of mix different things
in um here and there so i decided to
just go with the rock and the grass and
mix in some random light rock and random
sand textures and in the end that looks
pretty awesome and um now there's
something as you can see i'm kind of
doing that around the roller coaster it
has no specific real um idea behind it
though i must say that uh i've kind of
like seen that
when it comes to roller coasters and
especially the ground underneath the
trek people just like to play send over
there i don't know exactly why or how
all of that happened and it's not
entirely realistic because not all of
the real-life rollercoasters do that but
within the rct3 community so many people
do that and it's not it's not
necessarily a bad thing i do it as well
really i'm very guilty of doing that but
it's just something that i found it
looks pretty cool and many people do it
and it works so
really it's not as much as a rant about
this as it is a tip on people to kind of
do that because
if you don't really know what to do with
your terraforming it can always be a
great idea to just kind of place some
sand underneath the track it's pretty
cool and as you can see now it takes
quite a lot of time to do all that nist
picking and any little sand things
everywhere basically at this point i was
talking about this and i can barely hear
myself i should have turned on my volume
really because basically what happened
to my microphone my voice just came out
very weird and muffled in a way and i
can barely hear myself talk like um it's
not just a bad quality i can barely hear
it so it's it's gone all together so i
can't really use that anymore but anyway
i'm rambling um the thing the thing with
this was that oh god i forgot what i
wanted to say oh damn it well bit no
basically the commentary at this point
was pretty much me saying okay i'm going
to place grass here okay i'm going to
play sand here okay i'm going to play
some rocks here oh it's pretty cool and
uh in hindsight it was probably not the
best commentary though i still felt like
it was good commentary also you can see
that i just added some random grass over
there and yeah because
mixing
normal textures with these mixed
textures is also something that you can
do so it's pretty much mixception at
this point so
basically what this means
is that sometimes it just works to mix
in some normal textures without having
to use that whole checkerboard thingy
and um
like that so you can create some
contrast between the more darkers and
the lightest sand and add some grass uh
let's add some um the darker grass and
the lighter grass and add some sand
basically i i jump on everything up and
at this point you can kind of see me all
coming together you can kind of see the
grass and the sand and the way it all
behaves
and basically what i'm doing at this
point is just placing sand underneath
the paths just like doing this because
normally around paths you have
like some sand or soil or stuff like
that and it's not entirely all of all of
it is grass so if there's any place
where you want to have sand it's around
buildings around paths underneath tracks
and stuff like that that's basically how
it works
and
once again this this would have been
more me rambling about placing rocks and
cross and probably
rambling about random things in life
which i probably forgot at this point
anyway so screw that
and um
yeah that's pretty much it for this it's
really all i still need to do at this
point is just kind of finish that of
course i did experiment a bit with the
textures at that point and then felt
like no i don't want to use that dark
sand ah dark cross how do i keep messing
up how do i do that seriously and
i just felt like i kind of wanted to do
this as well i didn't want to make the
area in which i'm going to work too big
but i kind of wanted to do this to show
that there's there are also other ways
to do that to do this because i've been
using the rocks
up until this point and um you can also
use the asphalt it's pretty cool and
basically the way this works is you can
kind of predict it yeah your texture is
going to be just a little bit darker but
it's going to be less rough so you're
not going to have that rough rock
texture so
it works in a nice way very different
way and sometimes it also works better
for other climates or other types of
ground but really um
you can use the rocks and to get that
nice rough feel and not get your sand to
be too dark and but you can also use the
asphalt to get a really nice dark almost
um siberian forest if it weren't for the
fact that it'd be covered with snow
that's a bad example uh i don't know
just random forests in europe or
something like that that's basically how
it works when you have all the pine
trees and spruces and all that
and spruce is a pine tree isn't it and
but yeah that's basically i keep just
rambling on about things that's because
i'm doing kind of the same thing all in
this episode i couldn't pretty much say
what i've done until this point in just
a couple of words just use that
technique and just kind of experiment
and mess around with it that's basically
how it works now i also wanted to cover
foliage also because i kind of
promised that i would do it so well here
you go foliage by me
so i kind of
needed to look around and see what kind
of sets i should use and really i didn't
really have a clue honestly
this is always something in which you
kind of have to at least i do um so
don't blame me uh kind of have to look
around and
kind of look at sets and see what you
like kind of determine whatever what was
i doing at this point basically i'm just
okay so i finally opened the set and
it's it's it's spot it spices spices
trees and i know that i'm not going to
place anything with this so
get out
basically
i could talk about this for a second
spices trees is a pack that i really
love
but
i feel like it's not tropical enough and
it doesn't really fit the general vibe
and
atmosphere of this coaster so i decided
to go with asian sensation because it
does kind of have that tropical-ish feel
in it without having to go tropical b m
spam palm trees everywhere and dubstep
music feel and um kind of decided to go
with that and then decided to not go
with that and open station gyms
gardening too because station gyms
gardening 2 is the best thing since
sliced bread it's amazing it is the best
it is the king of foliage it is station
gyms gardening 2. and it's got the white
beams it's got everything it's got all
the amazing things and um so i decided
to just use that and as you can see this
is a pretty cool tree it's also a set
that's somewhat underused it's
relatively new and it had that little
fan uh when it just came out that
everybody used it but it's still kind of
underused and
really it's it's even though it's been
praised and
it's basically godly over at shy guys
world
it's not used that extremely often for
how good it is so really if i'd
recommend any foliage set i'd recommend
this because i would also recommend n7
sets and i could praise n7 for days but
everybody's already using that so
there's no point in really doing that i
all i can really do is just place the
things and put links to it and you all
know what's going on
but
also something that i kind of wanted to
address about this because you can see
that i'm basically taking 10 hours to
place three trees and be like silver
what are you doing this is not efficient
and um
basically what i wanted to say about
that is
um
what what i usually say is do grand
shrubbery first and then place trees
what i'd say in this case is do the
trees first make sure that you get them
exactly on the position where you want
them and then do the grand strawberry
like i'm doing right now now the point
of this is that first you kind of get
your general layout kind of um come to
terms with the way that you're building
things and then start doing the smaller
things and it doesn't really matter
because the one of the main reasons why
you're actually doing the grand jury
first or at least why i i would
recommend you to do that and why pretty
much all of the people in the rct3
community do that it's because it's
easier for one important reason that if
you place loads of trees and then you
want to do granularity you can't see any
you can't see the damn ground because
there's trees everywhere so you do the
grand jury first and then you kind of
know what to do and where to go and um
what kind of what kind of forest you're
creating and what kind of foliage you
want also you're kind of building up
from small foliage to bigger ones but
since this is just a very small area and
i kind of just want to have a few trees
surrounded by small bushes and stuff
like that
it's a better idea to place the trees
first
so what i'd say if you're creating a
forest or just doing foliage in general
on a roller coaster do the ground
shrubbery first don't make it too hard
on yourself just do the ground
strawberry and then move on to the trees
later on but if you're creating a very
small scene and you want everything to
be right like i i'm doing with this with
this cue
you should definitely do the trees first
and then do as i'm doing right now just
kind of look around and um kind of
experiment with um bushes and it really
give it some time i know that some
people are like um you shouldn't do this
just just place things uh it's really
important that you kind of look around
and look at bushes and see what you
really like for example i just had to
place a few bushes and then decide no
this is not going to be it and then you
can really decide that you want to
create an entirely different look and at
that point i felt like okay i'm going to
use these things i'm going to use the
crepe myrtles and um what's so what's so
great about these things is that they've
got great textures and they go so well
with this general theme and all the
other foliage so i just decided to go
with this instead after a bit of
experimenting and as you can see i'm
kind of lowering these things because
they're kind of like bushes trees and i
don't want that so i kind of lower them
speaking of lowering trees it's
something that i've been doing for years
i'm somewhat surprised that nobody's
actually been negative to me about that
it's the fact that i lower trees to make
them look like bushes really it's it's i
don't know if it's a bad thing or a good
thing i just find it a good thing
because it looks good in most cases so i
guess i'm going to give that as a tip as
well um
use trees and lower them to make bushes
and that's basically how that works
i just realized that the quality of this
video came out really weird in a sense
that as long as i hold the camera still
the quality is really good but then as
soon as i turn around it's 240p
this is uh this is not good
i need i need to work on this definitely
because the quality itself is not that
bad it just got it gets pixelated when i
turn
oh god this is not good anyway i'm
rambling again basically what i'm doing
at this point is just taking some
multiple bushes that you really like and
just kind of mess with them i know i
could have done a more um
well specific approach to the commentary
but the thing is that if you if you do
too specific if i really say okay do
this do that do this this and that
basically um people are gonna copy me
and that's not that's not the point of a
tutorial you shouldn't copy what's going
on only if you really want to learn but
the thing is that you should kind of
learn um
to do things yourself
see that that's an important thing of
tutorial it should teach you how to do
things yourself and it should not teach
you how to do things that others have
thought of be for you so
um this is kind of a general approach
that will work with anything really um
doesn't matter if you're doing a more
northern um
way of doing things than i am right now
just pick different trees but you can do
the same thing just kind of place for
example a couple of spruces in the
middle and some
smaller european bushes around that and
really it works in the same way just
with a different climate a different
theme etc
now um at this point i'm still trying to
experiment with bushes and see what i
like and also one important thing is
i had to look at the foliage that i
placed earlier and
realized that i kind of forgot about a
few bushes and
kind of wanted to place those things as
well so that's what i did with these
knot weeds so that's also something that
i'd say if you are doing foliage and
you've already done foliage earlier on
in your park then definitely look at
that foliage and kind of copy it i
wouldn't say that you'd have to do the
entire way uh the yeah just the same way
of doing the foliage all around the park
um actually i'd say the opposite just
try to to mix it up a little but um you
do kind of need to look at things and
make sure that it all looks somewhat the
same because just
in general that works well and at this
point i felt like i need some small
bushes some small little things on the
ground before i before i move into the
grass because grass you will see at the
end that grass is the magic thing it's
the most magical thing when it comes to
foliage really but i'll i'll say that
later i'll get to that bit in in a
moment and at that point i looked at
those things over there and i realized
hold on those aren't japanese whatever
they are they're european changers so
how to place the european gingers
doesn't really matter that i place those
other ones though because um one
nobody's gonna notice and two nature
just does things like that it mixes up a
little also speaking of nature there are
a few things
there are a few things that i want to
rent about and it it's also something
that i really need to say and some
people kind of forget and
first of all um you shouldn't strive
for perfect nature why because theme
parks aren't nature obviously of course
your park is going to have to look
somewhat natural because theme parks do
that too and i don't know why i was just
spinning around with that thing
but you don't need to make it entirely
natural because theme parks don't do
that the way that theme parks make their
foliage isn't natural it's meant to look
good and you should keep that in mind
while doing your foliage you don't have
to um well not place a tree simply
because you think oh well this isn't
natural it doesn't really matter as long
as it looks good and as long as it can i
can be maintained and that's my second
point basically you need to make sure
that your foliage can be maintained by
your people in your park so if you have
flowers don't put them in the middle of
nowhere where peop nobody can water them
and i don't know if i've said this
before i probably have and i can go on
about this forever but as long as people
keep messing this up i mean well okay
messing up it's a big boy but as long as
people keep doing this and um
if you really strive for a realistic
park you shouldn't do this because
simple you kind of need people to water
your plants and so you should think
about that now basically at this point
and this is a very very very very very
very important stage and i i didn't say
very enough because this is very
important and you should pay attention
you should pay very close attention um
beach fence said i was almost going to
say beach grass i was almost going to
say it simply because nobody uses this
set for the beach fans nobody does
everybody just use it everybody just
just think like the off fence and
moves onto the grass because the cross
is the great part about this set and
what everybody loves it basically you
have no grass in roller coaster second
three but beast cross is your number one
best friend and best alternative for
real grass basically what you have to do
just like with normal foliage just kind
of
place it around in clusters kind of like
that and make sure that you kind of
place it around other shrubs as well and
in bare areas i kind of mix it up with
the medium and the very small ones as
you can see i also place those big ones
but those big ones don't really work out
they're way too big they can work out on
an actual beach or in a swamp we're
trying to have a very small little pond
or something and you kind of want to
have some nice big rods on the sides or
maybe even in the middle of the pond
because that happens sometimes then
that's cool but in most other cases i
would go with medium and small and not
the large ones simply because they're
too big and they're gonna
be bigger than just normal shrubs and
flowers and that's not gonna look very
good but as you can see just kind of
place those medium ones especially those
medium ones around other shrubbery and
you can really see that the shrubbery
little
looks more realistic and it just looks
cooler in general so
i can't i i can go on about the set for
for days basically it's a great set it
really works make sure that you place
enough of this grass not too much not
too much because you don't want your
pike to look like um well
a stefano or something like that but it
depends on what climate and also on your
um well personal
taste really but
don't overdo this but really you can you
can just kind of look around and see at
some point when you're happy about it
then it should be all good and at this
point i am pretty happy with the grass
and the way that this bike is looking so
that's pretty good so i feel like at
this point i've pretty much finished
everything it's not really anything to
add at this point i think
no not really you can see that
just by adding that little bit of
foliage and nothing else it almost looks
as if the station itself is already
better as if the building itself is just
has improved in some sense well it
hasn't it's it's still the same building
but here you can really see the effects
of great foliage i've seen
coasters which aren't even that great
which i don't even have that great of
theming but with amazing foliage you can
make anything look good and i'm not even
kidding so never ever underestimate the
power of foliage now at this point i'm
just going to quickly add some rocky
textures to this little grass over here
i didn't bother to deal with that
that that very annoying technique simply
because even though it works out i felt
like meh i don't have the time nor do i
really want to deal with that again so i
just decided to play some just a few
rocky things now you shouldn't do this
if you really strive for the best
effects but if you feel like nah i don't
want to waste my time on anything
anymore or i just want to finish this
real quick then yeah you can do this as
long as you're kind of used to it
because it does take some time to kind
of get used to it and kind of get the
hang of where you need to place textures
and where you can shouldn't place
textures and what kind of textures work
well when you mix them but again that's
also
kind of you should kind of experiment
with that because that really works
now at this point
i don't really do anything new anymore
it's just trying to fix that little
ground thing over there and other things
but yeah basically this is the end of
the episode so thank you guys so much
for watching and hope you've learned
something despite the somewhat low
quality of me having to record this
again and see you all next time